prime terrible défaite dans la cinquième
partie du championnat du monde Jimmy
Rennes réagit avec brio en surclassant
des pommiacci dans la sixième avec les
pièces blanches sur le terrain
inhabituel du système de Londres il a
obtenu cette position où jouit d'une
très dangereuse batterie tour d'âme dans
la 7e rangée et à jouer dame F16 qui a
provoqué la bandeau immédiat de dépôt
alors pourquoi le Russe n'est-il trouvé
aucune défense ici qu'elle est donc la
menace admettons pour illustrer dame G5
un coup qui vient à la fois essayer de
défendre et d'attaquer et alors dame
prend tour sacrifice de dames et on
aboutit à un très joli mat des Arabes
caractérisé par le duo tour cavalier si
le roi va en Hachette il se fait punir
dans le coin par tourage Suisse et s'il
tente de s'échapper en F7 c'est le même
résultat tout fuite maths le pion
control la case de fuite direction que
nepo n'avait bien aucune solution dans
cette position il n'a pas d'échec le
cavalier contrôle la case et s'il tente
de le supprimer le pion reprend le roi
recule et de nouveau au sacrifier la
dame et dim peut parachever son
chef-d'œuvre par un mat du couloir